ROB LEWORTHY: Hello, welcome to
our first ever West End event
as part of Talks at Google.
My name's Rob Leworthy.
I'm one of the co-leads
here with Christina,
and I'm very pleased to welcome
Colin Cloud and Dave Williamson
from "The Illusionists," which
is playing just over the road
at the Shaftesbury
Theatre until January 3.
We're going do an interview
with them shortly,
but first we're
going to-- they're
going to do a small
act for us-- brilliant.
So let's start a round
of applause over here.
You sir, could you
start applauding for me?
And let's get the round of
applause going this way,
this way, this way, this way.
A massive [INAUDIBLE]
for Dave Williamson.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Oh!
Thank you very much.
There you go.
That is another key difference
between the United States
and England.
We always start our
applause from this side!
Amazing!
Everything's different.
Well, thank you.
This is great.
It gives me an opportunity
to do a little magic for you,
some of the things
that you wouldn't
see if you come to the show
across the street, which
we hope you do.
Let me try something.
Does anybody have a
piece of rope or string
about six feet in-- just
happen to have one right here.
Hi, sir!
You look very intelligent
with those glasses
and sitting up front.
You look like a go-getter.
That's what I think you are.
Would you examine
that piece of rope
and verify for all your friends
that there are no trapdoors,
escaping gases, strings,
mirrors, anything like that?
No Scientology in there.
There's a little
bit on the other end
but-- does it look OK?
OK, thank you very much for
dismissing the whole procedure.
Oh, looks like a rope.
I don't care.
Because in about
two minutes, you're
going to be going,
"I wish I would have
spent more time with the rope.
He's doing miracles
with that thing.
Obviously a trick rope, I didn't
take my job very seriously."
So here's your second chance
to really get into it.
Looks like a rope.
Check it out.
You will verify now when your
friends come to you at lunch
to go, "Really, what was
going on with the rope?"
You can now say with
honesty, "Looks like a rope,
still looks like a rope!"
Does anybody have
a bangle or a ring
or a bracelet, solid
with no gaps or openings,
about 10 inches in diameter,
steel, chrome plated?
I just happened to
have one as well!
We'll use mine.
Hi, sir, how are you?
Would you examine that?
Verify that that too
is absolutely solid.
There are no gaps or openings.
There is a little
weld spot there.
I see you went right to that.
Yeah, very good.
But I want you to make
sure it is a weld spot
and it's been chromed
over top of the weld.
There are no openings
or gaps, yes.
Does it look solid to you?
And I'm not going to do the hack
line, "Do you see any holes?"
And they say, "No," and I
go, "Right there, stupid."
I'm not going to do that to you.
I will not insult you.
And you got the memo
about the dress code.
Look at this guy, look at this.
He's a little David
Williamson here.
Mini me!
OK, Thank you.
[LAUGHING]
Awesome, just
revealed my double.
Now the switch will
not fool anyone.
Would you hold the ring?
Now here's the way
this one works.
This is an old puzzle.
These are folk puzzles.
So magicians-- modern
day magicians--
we comb through all the
archives of all the old puzzles
and we try to update them.
How do you take the ring off the
rope without untying the knot?
You can release there
Mongo, thank you.
How do you take the
ring off of the rope
without untying the knot?
It's kind of a Zen like concept.
If you think about
it, it can't be done,
but you can provide
the illusion.
If I double the rope through the
ring-- when I do this for kids,
I love to do magic for
people of all ages, I say,
"You know, any
difficult problem is
easy to solve with
the help of a friend,
and you're going
to be my friend."
I want you to hold
the ring only.
Close your eyes and count
to three, seriously.
He did it, nice job!
He has no idea how he
did it, but he did it.
So the skeptics
in the room always
say, "I know how you did that.
You didn't really put
the ring on the rope.
You were telling your dumb
jokes, and you went like this
and you created sort
of a confusing image.
So when you pull pulled
ring off the rope,
it was never really
on the rope."
And to them I say,
"That's right,
that's exactly how it's done.
There's no other way,
solid ring, solid rope."
I'd have to be a real
magician to actually pass
the ring through the rope.
What?
Here's the deal, and only
at Google would I do this,
I'm going to tell
you how it's done.
Yeah, because I think you
might find it interesting.
Would you hold the
ring once again?
And what is your name?
AUDIENCE: Graham.
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
Thank you, Graham.
Pair of scissors, cutting
through the rope like that.
Scissors cutting
through the rope.
Sir, you act like you
see this stuff every day.
He's just like, "I see
more amazing things
on my screen every day."
This is reality, it's
not-- it is reality,
it's actually happening, sir.
There are two pieces of rope
which are not exactly the same.
So I guess I cut it off center.
All right.
Ab Blaster, QVC, OK thank you.
Keep them stuck there.
That was superglue.
Bing!
No individual clapping, sir,
I appreciate that though.
I don't get out much.
OK, how do you--
watch the two ends
as they go into Dave's
pocket, except for this one.
Stays out here with this one.
Bing!
And this is the big applause
cue, the middle-- ta-dam-- bam!
Right there in the pocket.
You can examine
that again, Graham.
Thank you very much.
Thank you!
OK.
That went well.
Let's do another one.
OK, otherwise I'd just run
off and bring Colin up.
But I'll try another one since
you seem to be into this stuff.
Anybody shuffle cards?
Does anybody know their
way around a deck of cards
and know how to shuffle?
You?
OK, come on up here, give
him a round of applause.
Thank you, sir.
This is a deck of--
we call these seconds.
See how it says seconds?
Shuffle them up.
Make sure it's a real deck.
At the Shaftesbury Theatre
I destroy a deck of cards
every night.
We're doing over 80 performances
in the two months we're here,
and I said, "I'm not bringing
80 decks of cards in my luggage.
Go buy some from
the local store."
So they went and they
bought the cheapest--
they're called seconds,
and the printer-- there
might be little ink problems,
or there might be something
like that.
That's why they're
called seconds.
It doesn't look like a
regular deck of cards,
but it is a regular
deck of cards.
They just have some
irregular-- I don't even
know why I'm pointing that out.
It's not important to the trick.
Tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Yann.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Yann?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Yann.
Oh, I like that.
Take any card you like, Yann.
You sure?
I was hoping you'd go
for the one next to it.
All right, well we'll do
it a different trick, Yann.
Don't let me see
it, don't let me--
[LAUGHING]
Yann's juggling show!
Did you get it?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
Show it to everybody.
You can even show
it to the camera.
I will hide my eyes here
in the blackout curtain.
Can everybody see it?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
OK, hide it, Yann.
Here I come, face down.
Place it back in the pack.
Now let me just show
everybody, they're
all shuffled up
it's a normal deck,
you put it back in the pack
anywhere you like, Yann.
[LAUGHING]
--27.
OK, now, Yann, your card
is shuffled into the deck.
I like Yann's body
position there, he's
all closed-- never know
what to do with their hands.
OK, Yann, here's
what I'm going to do.
Do you remember your card?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: When I snap
my fingers, your card will jump
from the center of the
pack, believe it or not,
fly through the air, and I'll
catch it in my other hand.
Are you ready for this, Yann?
I don't know this--
is it-- OK, me too.
Here we go, watch.
[FINGERS SNAPPING]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE WILLIAMSON: 14 years of
my life to learn that crap.
Yann, what was your card?
AUDIENCE: Spades two.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Spades
two, is that right?
AUDIENCE: Sorry--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Controversy!
AUDIENCE: Language problem here.
Diamond, diamond.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Diamond?
AUDIENCE: Diamond two.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Diamond two!
And it's changed into
the three of clubs.
That's called magic
where I come from, Yann.
Was it really the spade
two, or was it the diamond
three, or what was it?
Anybody?
It really was the
two of diamonds.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: OK, I'm going
to have Colin come up here,
because this is not going well.
There it is, right where you
left it, 27 from the top.
No wonder it didn't find it!
OK.
When this happens-- that's
called live theater.
At the Shaftesbury,
it's more rehearsed.
I'm trying stuff
I've never tried.
Do me a favor, put your hand
on top of the torn pieces
of the three of clubs.
We're going to try this.
It doesn't always work,
but we're going try this.
We're going to take your
diamond two and stick it
under your hand.
I'm going to say
the magic words.
Hope to heck it works.
The card that was once torn,
Yann, the three of clubs?
Ooh, a chill just went up my--
What could possibly
be under your hand?
Turn the pieces over,
and show the people
that you do, in fact,
have the diamond two!
Ladies and gentlemen!
There it is!
Thank you, Yann.
Hold the pieces.
Make a fist.
Squeeze tight.
Hold your hand high in the air.
Do you believe in
the healing powers?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Not much.
No, no, where I come from you
have to have more conviction.
Say, "I believe."
Repeat after me.
I will never--
AUDIENCE: I will never--
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
Say what other--
AUDIENCE: Say what other--
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
People tell me to say.
AUDIENCE: People tell me to say.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE WILLIAMSON: OK, I'm
going to blow on your hand
with my laser breath.
Ooh, cool watch.
Open your hand.
Have those pieces indeed--
the healing powers of Yann.
He will blow on your
foreheads later, and make
all the wrinkles disappear.
There it is.
Give it up for Yann!
Yann, you're awesome,
thank you so much.
Wait a minute!
Go like this.
Blow on your hand.
Press on the card, and
say this word-- "Psst."
Like a steam press.
Lift up your hand.
Those wrinkles-- verify
that, Yann-- are gone.
That is steam pressed
as good as new.
There it is.
Give it up for Yann
on one more time.
Thank you, sir.
You can have that deck of cards.
There's the box.
Thanks, Yann.
OK, let me try one more.
I knew I was going to be coming
here for Google, technology
company, obviously.
So how do you combine
magic with technology?
I've done it.
I figured it out.
You're welcome.
Take an early lunch, OK.
This is a deck of
cards, and if you
think about what a deck
of cards is-- and I know
Ollie's going to give us a
close up of the table here.
If you think about what a deck
of cards is, a deck of cards
is a collection of
information, right?
Colors, numbers, suits,
kind of like a database.
Let's keep that shot
there, if we don't
mind so that everybody can see.
Now, this is an
interesting deck of cards
because I've run them
through a little printer.
Now let's find somebody--
an uninterested party.
You haven't seemed
interested the whole time.
Hi, would you help me?
As I riffle my thumb
through-- what are you doing?
Why are you
approaching magic Dave?
Just stay in your seat.
Oh my god.
Just point at you,
hey, it's all about me!
Come on.
Let me have some me time,
I don't get enough over
there at the
theater every night.
I'm kidding, what is your name?
AUDIENCE: Christina.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Christina,
all I'm going to ask you to do
is just call the word stop as I
pull my thumb through the pack.
That way you'll randomly
select one of the cards.
AUDIENCE: Stop.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Right there?
All right, that will be
your randomly selected card.
Please remember it.
I will avert my gaze so
I do not see what it is.
[LAUGHTER]
I can't see that.
That's too far.
Five of hearts, OK.
Now watch this.
Now Ollie, let's see if we
get that really close shot
that we talked about earlier.
Here's what I'm going to do.
There we go, yes,
super close, I love it.
I love it.
Look at that.
Here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to give
the deck a shuffle.
Now, this is a very
special shuffle.
Let's call it the
Google shuffle.
You interleave the
cards, and if you
think of this like a
computer screen, 52
scan lines of resolution,
AUDIENCE: Whoa!
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
It actually starts
to say the word unshuffle,
which is what I'm doing.
I'm shuffling the cards but
I'm separating the four suits.
Let me do that again.
The more I shuffle, the
more unshuffled they become.
Look at the screen, no batteries
required, beautiful resolution.
One final shuffle and
it becomes very clear
that Magic Dave had a lot of
by-himself-time as a child.
Sitting in his house
shuffling cards.
All the other kids were
out playing football
and talking to girls.
The deck is
completely unshuffled.
What does that mean, unshuffled?
Well if you remember, I showed
you a shuffled deck of cards,
but if you look at
them now-- we'll
get that close up shot again,
if you don't mind there Ollie.
They're all in order.
All the spades are in order,
diamonds, clubs hearts,
and spades, all the diamonds,
all the clubs, all the hearts,
all the spades,
ace through king,
just like they came
from the factory.
That is an unshuffled deck.
But I know what you're saying.
You're saying, "Wait a minute,
Dave, that's not magic,
that's technology.
We do that better than you."
It's true.
But there was a famous quote,
and I'm sure all of you
know it, by Arthur C. Clarke.
I'm going to shuffle
them again, spades into
the clubs, diamonds
into the hearts.
He said very famously,
"Any sufficiently advanced
technology is
indistinguishable from magic."
I always love that quote.
What was your card,
Christine, do you remember?
Don't remember?
AUDIENCE: Five of hearts.
Five of hearts.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Five of hearts.
There it is, thank you, folks.
Thank you very much.
All right, thank you.
That's my time.
It is my true pleasure to
introduce the next artist,
and he's making huge waves
over at the Shaftesbury Theatre
in The Illusionists, and
it's a pure pleasure spending
time with him.
You'll be seeing him
on your television
soon and touring live.
Please welcome the
amazing Colin Cloud.
There he is.
[APPLAUSE]
COLIN CLOUD: Thank you.
Very good afternoon.
Are you well?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
COLIN CLOUD: Good, there was
almost an awkward pause there,
I was worried.
But before we go any
further, before I tell you
anything about you, I
think it's only right you
know a tiny bit about me.
I'm not actually from
this part of the world.
I'm from a place up right
in the middle of Scotland.
A place that you may
have been to, heard of,
avoided, I don't know.
It's a place called Harthill.
That is the most
positive reaction
I've ever had for Harthill.
But I left there very quickly.
I went to university
in Glasgow, where
I got my honors degree in what's
called forensic investigation.
People usually clap or
cheer at that point.
[APPLAUSE]
12 of you, thank you.
And I specialize in what's
called criminal profiling.
That's not why
you're here today.
Some of you actually shifted
your position on your chair.
But it has led to me learning
some pretty weird and amazing
things to do with the mind,
especially when it comes
to Sherlock Holmes, who is my
inspiration for everything I
do.
Arthur Conan Doyle
once famously wrote
that "By a man's
fingernails, by his shirt
cuff, by the calluses on
his thumb and forefinger,
by his expression, by each of
these things a man's calling is
plainly revealed."
Notice he only mentioned
men, because even back then,
he knew it was impossible
to read a woman's mind.
Not an idiot.
But everything he
did fascinates me.
The idea of memory, knowledge,
deduction-- and that's
why I want to play with
right now with all of you.
Let's just take this deck.
Would you mind giving
this half a shuffle?
And would you do the exact same?
Just mix up those
cards, shuffle them up.
In a moment, not yet, I'm
going to ask some of you
to lend weird or unusual
objects that you have with you
in your pockets or your bags.
If you have-- don't
bring it out just yet,
it's important that I
never see what it is.
But if you could think, if you
have something weird or unusual
that isn't just an
iPhone, wallet, watch,
that would be amazing, OK?
May I take these?
And would you point out
someone here behind you
that you don't know?
This gentleman right here.
Would you please take
half of the cards?
Hold on to them.
Don't do anything.
If you want to shuffle them
one more time, you can.
And behind you, someone
that you don't know.
This lady right here.
So you take them.
Would you please take
this half of the cards?
Perfect.
Right, don't do
anything with them
yet other than mix them up a
little bit more if you want to.
That's totally fine.
But I also need
the help of someone
who has experience
in blindfolding.
Not the sort of
thing you normally
admit to at a public event,
but I notice about eight
of you perked up there.
Let's go for a-- lady, blonde
hair, hi, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Caroline.
COLIN CLOUD: Again?
COLIN CLOUD: Carradine?
AUDIENCE: Caroline.
COLIN CLOUD: Caroline.
AUDIENCE: Caroline, yeah.
Look at me.
[SNAPS FINGERS]
Now it's Caroline.
Caroline?
AUDIENCE: Caroline, yes.
COLIN CLOUD: Perfect.
Would you please stand up?
Does this lady look
like the sort of person
that we can trust?
Interesting hesitation.
I'm going to trust you.
Give her a huge hand as
she makes her way up.
I won't embarrass you, OK?
Would you please stand
right here for me?
Good, I'm going to
move this table.
Wow, it's heavier than
it looked in the photos.
You will see a few
things that we're
going to use, OK, in a moment.
Not yet.
Would you, first of all,
check these two 50p coins
are real, regular 50p coins?
Make sure there is nothing
weird or unusual about them.
Just regular coins.
Hold them up to the light.
Make sure no little holes,
trapdoors, anything, solid.
Yeah, some people like
to bite on them as well.
AUDIENCE: No, that's all right.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Cool.
No one's ever done that.
But they are real, right?
You can set them
back on the table,
and also this is a Kevlar scarf.
You can make sure that no light
comes through this, correct?
Perfect.
The eyelid is one of
the weakest muscles
we have in the human body,
and you can try this.
If you close one eyelid,
even the slightest amount
of pressure on that
eyelid will mean
that it's impossible to open
up your eye, the slightest
amount of pressure.
So we're going to
lock my eyelids closed
in place with the 50p coins held
in position buy gaffer tape.
Things just got very "Fifty
Shades of Grey," right?
First of all, make sure that
coin is on there solid, yes?
Perfect.
Can you see the rest of
the tape all along there?
I've tried to fold
in the edges so
that you can pick it up easily
from the material in case
it's stuck.
But you can all see
that coin goes right
over my right eye socket.
Could you hold your
right hand up like this?
Use this part of your
hand to press it down.
Only use that part.
Don't use your fingers,
otherwise you'll
get, like, a popping sound,
and we don't want that, right?
So just press that down.
Perfect.
Happy that that's
stuck there, yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes, that's good.
COLIN CLOUD: When this
next piece goes on,
I will no longer,
obviously, be able to see,
but you can see the rest
of the tape here, yes?
And if you do have a weird
or-- what a great time to walk
in late, I mean really.
Wow.
Welcome to the pirate show.
If you have a weird
or unusual object,
this is the time to think
about it and get it ready, OK?
So you can see this coin here
goes into this eye socket,
and again would you
please press that down?
Thank you very much.
Take the next piece of tape.
There's a few spare.
We don't need to use them
all if we don't have time,
but I want to cover my face
with as much of that tape--
have you got a piece?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
COLIN CLOUD: Perfect, we'll put
that where my eyes used to be.
Take the next piece.
You just keep
grabbing the pieces.
Everyone now in the room, get
your weird or unusual object
ready, because in
a moment, we're
going to grab-- borrow
a few of these, OK?
Two more pieces I
think are on there?
Yes, perfect.
We'll put this part a little
bit lower for anyone that
thinks I can see down the way.
And there's one more
piece on there as well.
You're going to press those
all down again yourself.
One more piece.
We'll put that just underneath
here for anyone that
thinks that's where I can see.
Could you press all
that down and make sure
that it's definitely stuck?
AUDIENCE: It's stuck.
COLIN CLOUD: Do press around
the bottom of my eyes.
Even just with your fingers
now just beneath my eyes.
Make sure that it's stuck to my
flesh all the way around, yes?
AUDIENCE: It is.
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah,
she's done this before.
Right, pick up the scarf.
The scarf I just
showed you, yeah?
Could you lay that
across my two palms.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to throw
the two ends behind.
Can you grab the two ends, and
tie them in a nice tight knot?
Tighter, tighter, play rough.
And double knot it as well.
Happy?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
COLIN CLOUD: Lovely.
Could you now go out
into the audience--
take my right hand,
first of all--
and put my fingertips on
the middle of the table
so that I get my
bearings and balance, OK?
Would you now please
very carefully
go out-- if you
have a weird object,
quietly hold it up in
the air so that she
can see where they are.
Go out and collect three
of them for me, OK?
Do that now.
The four of you who do now
have cards from the deck,
could you now spread them so
that you can see all the cards?
Say yes over here if
you can see yours.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
COLIN CLOUD: Yes,
yes, and yes, yes.
So you're spreading them.
I want you all to say out
loud the first card that you
can see in your spread now.
[SNAPS FINGERS]
AUDIENCE: Nine of spades.
COLIN CLOUD: At
the same time, OK?
So one more time.
That's all right, that's okay.
At the same time
say it out loud now.
[SNAPS FINGERS]
AUDIENCE: [SAYING CARDS]
COLIN CLOUD: Perfect.
Say the second card, now.
[SNAPS FINGERS]
AUDIENCE: [SAYING CARDS]
COLIN CLOUD: Let's get faster.
The next card.
AUDIENCE: [SAYING CARDS]
COLIN CLOUD: Next, faster.
COLIN CLOUD: Faster.
Keep going.
Faster.
Keep going, keep
saying them louder.
Louder, faster, faster.
Make sure you go all
the way to the end.
Say all of them.
AUDIENCE: [SAYING CARDS]
COLIN CLOUD: Done, right.
What I need all four
of you to do now
is sort them into the suit.
So all the spades together,
the hearts together,
clubs together, and
diamonds together, OK?
Do that right now and I'll
come back to you in a second.
As soon as you get those
three objects, Caroline,
if you can come back
up to the stage.
And I'll know that
you're coming back
because everyone's going to give
you a huge round of applause
as you make your way back.
[APPLAUSE]
COLIN CLOUD: Are you back?
Good.
The table is roughly here.
Could you lay the
objects in a line
so that everyone
else can see them?
Please do not say
what the objects are.
Did you get two or
did you get three?
AUDIENCE: I got three.
COLIN CLOUD: You've
got three, perfect.
If you see what they are, please
again don't say it out loud.
What I would like you to do
first of all-- are you still
here?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
COLIN CLOUD: With
your right hand,
pick up any one of the objects.
Hold it nice and high.
I'm going to ask the
camera just doesn't zoom in
on this just yet until we
see-- this is just slipping.
I just want to make
it tighter-- right,
just so that we don't
see what it is, OK?
So, the person that owns
this object, can you please
say the word hello?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
COLIN CLOUD: Hello.
Do you know the game
word association?
Where someone says a word and
you say a word connected to it.
Like if I said, "banana,"
you could say, "apple."
But you could also say
"cherry" or "pear."
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: OK.
COLIN CLOUD: I'm going
to ask you three words,
and say the next thing
that comes to mind.
Do not say your object.
Just keep the object at
the back of your mind, OK?
So word number one--
say the next thing
that comes to mind-- word
number one is the word snowman.
AUDIENCE: Carrot.
COLIN CLOUD: Again?
COLIN CLOUD: Carrot.
Word number two
is the word water.
AUDIENCE: Bottle.
COLIN CLOUD: Bottle.
And word number three
is the word chair.
AUDIENCE: Desk.
COLIN CLOUD: Quite an aggressive
desk as well there, I noticed.
Right, I think I know-- I'm
going to struggle with that.
Sit that one back down, I'm
going to come back to you
in a second.
Pick up a different
object for me.
Just still warming up.
I'm going to try and
get all of these, OK?
Pick up a different object.
Hold it nice and high.
Can the person who owns
this object say hello?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
COLIN CLOUD: We'll try this
in two words with you, OK?
So same game.
Say the next thing
that comes to mind.
So word number one
is the word deep.
AUDIENCE: Cold.
COLIN CLOUD: Again.
COLIN CLOUD: Pool?
AUDIENCE: Cold.
COLIN CLOUD: Oh, thank
you for translating.
Word number two
is the word snow.
AUDIENCE: Snowman.
COLIN CLOUD: Snowman.
OK, I think I've got it.
Set it back down, there should
be one object left, yes?
Pick up that object.
Can the person who
owns it say hello?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
COLIN CLOUD: Do you play
sports, sir, first of all?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
COLIN CLOUD: Yes,
what's your main sport?
AUDIENCE: Basketball.
COLIN CLOUD: I'm going to try
this in one word with you, OK?
The word I'm going to give
you is the word cheese.
AUDIENCE: Grater.
COLIN CLOUD: Sit that
object back down.
I think the first object--
we'll go back to that
with the three words over here.
Hold it nice and high.
Is this something
sentimental with you?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
COLIN CLOUD: Yes.
You had it for a while, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
COLIN CLOUD: Was
it given to you,
or did you pick it up yourself
when you were somewhere
specific?
AUDIENCE: It was given to me.
COLIN CLOUD: Given to you.
It's going to be some
kind of like, I think,
little charm type thing.
I either thought was going to
be a little-- it's not a tennis
ball, is it?
AUDIENCE: No.
COLIN CLOUD: No.
Is it some kind of
rock with some kind
of little chain attached to it?
Is that kind of close?
AUDIENCE: Sort of.
COLIN CLOUD: Sort of.
I think that's as close
as I'm going to get.
I'm still warming up with
you, right, but tell us,
what is the object?
How close am I?
AUDIENCE: You're quite close.
You got the chain.
COLIN CLOUD: What
is on the chain?
Is it like a little
rock or a pebble?
AUDIENCE: No, it's
a little soft toy.
COLIN CLOUD: A little soft toy.
Oh!
But it's on a chain, though.
I was right with, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes, you are.
COLIN CLOUD: I'm
going to take that.
Right.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
You take my hand again.
The second thing,
where were you?
Say hello again back here--
AUDIENCE: Hello.
COLIN CLOUD: Hello.
With you I'm going to be honest.
Was it something--
was it a plaster?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
COLIN CLOUD: Is
that what it was?
Yes!
[APPLAUSE]
And, the final one was
only one word, right?
So I don't know
exactly-- is this the man
I said the word cheese to?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
COLIN CLOUD: Hello.
This isn't a
glasses case, is it?
AUDIENCE: No.
COLIN CLOUD: No.
Then it's going to be
some kind of little glass
bottle with liquid inside.
I'm going to guess probably some
kind of aftershave or fragrance
type thing.
Is that pretty close?
Yes?
[APPLAUSE]
Excellent.
Caroline, take my right hand.
Could you put it back on the
middle of the table again?
Perfect.
I move around quite
a lot when I do this.
So would you please pick
up the three objects,
give them back to the people
who just let them to us,
and you'll get a huge round
of applause for helping.
Give it up for Caroline.
Thank you!
[APPLAUSE]
And let me just-- this is
my least favorite part.
If I look surprised
when this comes off,
it's because I no
longer have eyebrows.
And you're all still here.
Thank you.
So, four of you-- that's a gift.
Try it later.
The four of you
with playing cards
sorted them into order, yes?
OK, could I ask you please
to stand up where you are.
Try and cover the
backs of the cards
as well so that no one thinks
I can see what they are.
In fact, just for ease
I think it will be great
if the four of you-- can we give
them a welcome onto the stage?
Give them a hand
as they come up.
If you'd please stand
right here for me.
Can I please ask that
you just stand over here?
Hello.
Nicely covered.
And would you come
and stand right here?
OK, so this way you
can see if I'm right,
and I will join all of you.
Someone name a suit
in the playing cards.
AUDIENCE: Hearts.
COLIN CLOUD: Hearts.
Could you all now hold the
cards so that you can see them?
I'll warm up facing you.
I will turn away in a
second, but just so I
make sure I've got you in the
right way I've remembered you.
Would I be right in saying that
you have the ace of hearts?
Yes.
You also have the two?
But you've got the three?
Yeah?
You've got the four?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
COLIN CLOUD: You've
got the five.
You've got the six.
You've got the
seven and the eight.
You've got the nine, the 10.
You got the jack.
You've got the queen.
You've got the king.
Yes, good, right!
[APPLAUSE]
There are two that I
have misheard, right?
So I'll come back to them if
I've-- three of you were a bit
louder, but that's OK.
Name a different suit.
AUDIENCE: Clubs.
COLIN CLOUD: Clubs.
You've got the ace of clubs.
AUDIENCE: Which one is clubs?
COLIN CLOUD: The
one-- no, that's OK.
The one that looks like
a little puppy paw.
Welcome to Google.
[LAUGHTER]
Something to search
later, right?
Do you see?
Perfect, thank you, thank you.
It's funny, right, if you're
not used to cards, though,
so thank you so
much for helping.
But you've got the ace.
Yes?
You've got the two.
You've got the three.
You've got the four.
You've also got the five.
You've got the six.
You've got the seven.
You've got the eight.
You've got the nine as well.
You've got the 10.
Yes?
You've got the jack.
You've got the queen.
And you've got the king.
Yes good, right.
Let's get faster.
Hearts and clubs,
two suits left.
Name a different suit.
AUDIENCE: Diamonds.
COLIN CLOUD: Diamonds.
Diamonds, diamonds, diamonds.
Let's get faster.
You've got the ace of diamonds.
You've got the two.
Yes?
You've got the three.
You've got the four.
You've got the five.
Yes, you've got the six.
You've got the seven,
and you've got the eight.
You've got the nine, the 10.
You've got the jack.
You've got the queen.
And you've got the king.
Yes, good.
One last suit, which
is obviously spades.
So we'll do this
very fast, OK we'll
do this very, very
quickly, and then we--
You've got the ace of spades.
Yeah, you've got the two.
You've got the three.
You've got the four.
You've got the five.
You've got the six.
You've got the seven.
You've got the eight.
You've got the nine.
You've got the 10.
You've got the jack.
You've got the queen.
You've got the king, and
you've got the joker.
You were wondering whether
or not I was going to say it.
Is that right?
Yes!
Give them all a huge
round of applause.
Leave the cards on the table.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
ROB LEWORTHY: Thank you
again Colin Cloud and Dave
Williamson.
Thank you so much for coming in.
So you're on the show
"The Illusionists."
Perhaps you could tell us
about the show and how you got
involved in it.
COLIN CLOUD: So the
show essentially-- it's
like a mashup of
different genres of magic,
and in my opinion, every
performer in that show
was at the top of their game for
the genre of magic or mystery
entertainment that
it is they do.
And the show essentially
is a showcase
of that variety over the
course of an evening.
It's fast paced.
You picked up on the fact that
there's a live band there.
It's made to feel very
much, to an extent,
like a bit of a sort of
upbeat, energetic type piece.
And yeah, it's been
going very well.
ROB LEWORTHY: And it's
playing in Broadway,
and touring North America, so--
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah, it's quite
the commute every morning,
it's hellish.
ROB LEWORTHY: And
so the different
iterations of the
show, how did--
Did you have to work within
a preexisting format,
or did you kind of bring
your own things to it?
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Well,
there is a format.
This show started in
the Sydney Opera House
about four years ago
during a festival.
And the producers put
together these genres--
they brought an illusionist,
and they brought a comedy act,
and they brought a
mentalist, and a manipulator,
a classic manipulator.
And it went down so well
that it was extended,
and then it went on
tour in Australia,
and then they realised that
there was a market for it.
People just love the show,
so it has been touring
the world for three years.
So in North America,
it's been on tour,
and when this
opportunity came up
to bring the show
to the West End,
Broadway said, "Well, bring
it to Broadway as well
at the same time."
So basically, the producers
took the main cast,
split them in half, put each
half in a different city,
and then sort of
filled in the slots,
basically, with
other entertainers.
And there's a third tour right
now happening in Australia.
It's called "The
Illusionists 1903."
And that's a completely
different cast.
And it's less rock
and roll, less glitzy.
It's a throwback
to the Vaudeville,
the classic era of-- the golden
age of variety entertainment.
ROB LEWORTHY: And
with-- Derren Brown
is playing just
down the road here,
and we've had-- "The Impossible"
was in London last year.
So do you think there's a
resurgence in seeing magic
live?
Is that something that's
come off recently?
Or--
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah,
I think-- I mean
magic is something-- I
mean, you see it on TV
and you dismiss it right away as
a camera trick, or as stooges,
if you want, right?
Whereas I think
it's like anything.
You can listen to a CD in
the car, but to actually go
see the band live is a
totally different experience.
And certainly, with
a show like ours,
what it does, as
you've seen, rely
a lot on audience interaction,
and the assistance of-- I
mean it's fully
immersive, so it's
a completely
different experience
to any other type of
theater or musical
that's happening in the
West End at the moment.
And I'm glad, delighted, that
it has become more popular,
and people can now
go see quality,
live magic entertainment.
ROB LEWORTHY: So when you're
coming up with a new illusion,
do you start with a story
that you want to tell,
or do you start
with a trick itself?
Where do you start
on that journey?
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Well, I think
early on in your career you
start with the trick itself.
You say, "Oh, I want to
do this amazing trick,
and just amaze people."
But then as you get on and
you build a career out of it,
you realize that there
are stories to tell,
and there are emotions
to tap, and there's
a narrative you
may want to push,
and I think that's an evolution
of a career that-- people who
begin in magic, it's all about
the tricks or the secrets
and, you know, worship me.
I mean, I think at its
core, every entertainer
is just looking for love.
Basically, it's attention
getting, you know?
"Look at me."
And then as you mature and your
career becomes a little more,
you know-- I need
to Google this.
I'm at a loss for words here.
You understand what
I'm trying to say.
ROB LEWORTHY: So I think
I was blown away, perhaps,
because I've seen you
Colin at the [INAUDIBLE]
before, in quite a
small intimate venue.
So how does working in a 1,200
seat theatre differ from either
doing close up magic,
Dave that you do,
versus kind of a
small fringe venue?
COLIN CLOUD: I think,
bizarrely, it's easier.
Certainly the theater we are in,
it's a huge theater, you know?
1,400 seats.
But it still feels
very intimate.
So for me, the more people
there are, the easier it is.
This is the smallest
performance I've
done now in the last few
months, and it's terrifying.
I can feel you all looking
at me, and it's-- I hate it.
[LAUGHTER]
But no, the more people
there are, the more energy,
and people are
there because they
want to see that type of thing.
So they're on our
team from the off,
and it's just an
absolute delight.
ROB LEWORTHY: And how
did you get into magic?
COLIN CLOUD: Genuinely, I
was never really into magic
until later on, because
I was fascinated
by, genuinely, Sherlock
Holmes at eight years old.
When I was 10, discovered
he never actually existed.
Got it, yeah.
Two people awwed, thank you.
But by then the bug had bit, and
I was really big into science,
and more genuinely, hypnosis
than I was ever with magic.
But then I realized
Sherlock Holmes
had this wonderful
esoteric skill
set of pickpocketing, lock
picking, which then led
kind of more into that.
So it was much of reading
people and situations.
He had these other
skills, and my fascination
more grew from that.
ROB LEWORTHY: Because I
was the eight-year-old
boy with the Paul
Daniels magic kit.
I think that's kind of where
I kind of played with that--
COLIN CLOUD: See I got that,
but then my cousin Karen,
she was way better at the tricks
than me, so put me right off.
ROB LEWORTHY: And
Dave, what about you?
DAVE WILLIAMSON: I have the
classic story of the magic set
for the birthday party
at eight years old,
and then you go to
the library and you
realize that if you
don't return the books,
your friends will
never see the secret.
So of course, I have all the
original library books still
in my home.
As do all my magician friends.
They still-- I can
tell where they grew up
by their library books.
They still contain--
But yeah, so I've been
doing it since I was a kid.
I was bit by the
magic bug very early.
I turned to my mother
when I was age 10
and I said, "I'm going to be
a professional magician, worry
about my brothers, that's
what I'm going to do."
And she was a great mother.
This was back in the 70s.
She used to drop me off at
these little magic gatherings
and festivals, or send me on
a bus to a different state
at the age of 12, and 13, and
14, with a note pinned to my--
you know?
And she let me go,
and I've been just
swimming around in this
world of magic ever since.
ROB LEWORTHY: Is
there a big difference
in the magic scene between the
UK in the US, do you think?
COLIN CLOUD: With regards to
the performance, the audiences?
I think every culture in
the world has areas of magic
that they strive in more.
So for example, in
the UK, Derren Brown
has been a massive figure here.
So that type of entertainment,
the more mentalism type stuff
has become more popular.
We see a lot of
Asian magicians are
more interested in
the manipulation type.
America, I find it's really
quality close up magic there.
So I mean, really,
every country seems
to have the thing
that they are best at,
and it's always nice
to visit these places
and become more inspired
by their approach.
ROB LEWORTHY: And "The
Illusionists" felt like a very
international cast, which--
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
Absolutely, yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Final
question from me.
So if you have any
audience questions,
do please go stand behind
the mic in the middle.
YouTube.
Google owns YouTube,
and so what do
you think of magic on YouTube?
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
Well, I'll tell you
the thing that YouTube
has really done
is, obviously, promote the art.
When I was a kid, when
I was 12 years old
and I wanted to learn
a move or a trick,
I had to wait until
that next magic festival
in the summertime
in Colon, Michigan
when I would meet
my friend again,
and we could swap stories.
Or maybe I'd write
a letter, and that's
how the magicians communicated.
But now you have somebody in
Ohio, a 12-year-old kid, put
a move on YouTube, and
half an hour later,
somebody in Singapore
has made an improvement,
and they're
crowdsourcing this idea.
And it's amazing the rapid
advancement made possible
by YouTube.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was just wondering how often
things go wrong, if they do,
and what you normally
do to cover them?
Do you admit it?
Do you try and work around it?
Or something else.
COLIN CLOUD: Some nights
in the Shaftesbury,
you'll see the best illusion
show you'll ever see,
and on other nights
you'll see the best comedy
show you've ever seen.
I mean that's the thing, right?
Any speaker, the more you
stand in front of an audience,
you learn to just
relax, become aware.
If things go wrong,
do you know what?
At the end of the day,
hopefully no one's died, right?
We're all human,
and-- fingers crossed.
So yeah, you laugh
about it, you move on,
and you make it still as
entertaining and as enjoyable
as possible, right?
It's designed to be fun.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Yeah, and for
a live show, I-- In my act,
I have the most dangerous
act in the show,
because I bring up
children on stage,
and I give them the
microphone, and I
let them say whatever's
on their minds.
ROB LEWORTHY: The
show I saw Saturday,
you had a four-year-old
which I thought was--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: It's fantastic.
Yeah, they're right
on the knife's edge
of wetting their
pants and crying
or having a wonderful time.
You don't know what's
going to happen.
And I'm talking about some
of the performers, too.
So I embrace the chaos.
So you're almost kind of
feeding little seeds out, hoping
that something unexpected--
because as Colin says,
that's where the gold is.
When something real and
human and off script happens.
So that's the beauty
of having a live show.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys plan
for different eventualities?
Or is there always
like a fixed--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Over time,
they just kind of take root.
You have different pathways
you know you can take.
You don't panic as much.
But yeah, early on--
COLIN CLOUD: And
certain ad libs become
learned and just in the bank.
If something happens, you'll
know that you can tap into it
and just keep the show moving
in the right direction.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: But
every so often, things
happen that we just-- you're
gobsmacked and you stand there.
Like when the train didn't
appear the other night.
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah.
Yeah, quite the sentence
when you don't know
what we're talking about.
It sounds like we
missed our lift home.
He does mean in the show.
It's amazing.
It's amazing, right?
But yes.
So technical things can
happen, but you laugh about it,
you move on, and
you just pick it up,
and you just do more amazing
things later to cover it.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: And that's
the thing about our show.
If you don't like what's
happening, don't worry.
10 minutes later, something
completely different
will be happening, and
it moves very fast.
ROB LEWORTHY: How do
you deal-- because I
think of the two of you, you
work with the audience most.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: And
Jamie does as well.
ROB LEWORTHY:
How do you deal with
different audience members?
Do you get good at picking the
right people, and so forth?
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah, I mean I
think it becomes like anything.
Even standing here, I could
look out and see the people
that-- you can tell who
just wants to sit there
and watch, and pick it
apart and try and work out
what's happening.
And then you get the people who
you can tell-- and thank you
for helping again-- but who are
going to be good characters,
and you can tell who's going
to be difficult on stage.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Like Yann.
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
And more who to avoid and
more who to aim towards.
And ultimately, I think
the goal of any performer
is to make other people look
good-- as good as possible,
and bring out the
best in people.
If I bring someone up and they
look bad, that reflects on me.
I want to bring people
up, make them look good,
feel good, because then
it just carries the show.
ROB LEWORTHY: Very good.
Any more questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So since
you mentioned YouTube,
one question came to mind.
Do you think that the very fact
that magic became so popular,
and you can see the
explanation of so many tricks
and YouTube and the
internet in general,
do you think it affected the
show if people somehow figured
out parts of the some tricks?
And do you think this
actually matters?
Would the people enjoy
the show, in your opinion,
even if they figure it out?
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
It's a good question.
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah, I
mean, ultimately, I
would hope that even
if I stand on stage
and do nothing, hopefully
I'm entertaining enough
that you'll enjoy that time.
So the other things
hopefully then become
the fuel for the fire to then
make it "The Illusionists"
and, you know, show
that it is, essentially.
But things like YouTube
and things being picked
apart-- if people are going
to go looking for the methods,
it's because they have
a genuine interest
in that way of thinking
and being inspired by it.
On some level, we had
to learn at some point
how things worked as well.
And if people go to the lens to
find out how things are done,
then it's because they
are passionate about it
to some extent.
But I also think people who
just want to enjoy the magic
will never go looking
anyway, so it's fun--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: But
it is a new phenomenon
to have somebody in the
audience with their phone
bringing up a video of how
they just did that trick.
I mean, Houdini didn't have
to deal with that, and we do.
And there's a wonderful
Asian performer.
He's from Taiwan, but he was
on television, CCTV in China.
And it's a different
culture there.
They don't have a history
of theatrical magic,
and when he went on the
largest television program
and did his close up
magic, before the end
of the program there
were-- I think it was Yuku?
Right?
Is that the Chinese--
ROB LEWORTHY: Baidu?
Baidu?
Is it Baidu?
The search engine.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Could be it.
Anyway, it was viral.
Somebody had made
a 3-D rendering
of how the table worked, and
that made front page news
the next day.
So it was a game
of cat and mouse.
And he found himself
constantly battling--
and that was the narrative was
let's catch out this performer
every time he goes on
TV, rather than what
a wonderful show
and an entertainer.
It was like, it's a
cat and mouse game.
COLIN CLOUD: What I have
found interesting with that,
though, is that people
that see the YouTube video,
then when that conversation
comes up in a social setting,
they will try and reenact
it for their friends.
And they'll try and act it
out, and they immediately
see how difficult
it actually is.
And what it does is even
if you know how it's done,
knowing how it's done,
and being able to do
it are two very
different things.
And I think it's how people
realize the amount of practice
and dedication that
needs to go into,
for example, the manipulations
that you see in the show.
I mean that is-- it
looks so magical,
and it's utter, raw skill
that he's put in the time
to make this wonderful
artistic piece.
Even my watching
it-- I introduce him,
and I'm on right after him,
so I see it every night.
And even seeing it
now 30 times in a row,
you still need to admire
how wonderful that
is that he's able to make--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: The most
wonderful moment in the show
is when Dne Den, our
manipulator, is on stage,
all the other magicians
are now in the wings
watching from the
wings every night.
And it's just a
wonderful picture.
ROB LEWORTHY: And you
close with Den Den doing--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Some close up
magic, yeah some very nice--
ROB LEWORTHY: And you're all
on stage at the same time,
and I just felt you were all
going, "This guy is amazing."
DAVE WILLIAMSON: He is.
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: A magician's
magician, if you will.
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I
wondered what your opinion
of people like Derren Brown,
and Dynamo, and David Blaine.
Are they like the best
of the field, or--
COLIN CLOUD: Who, sorry?
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
Never heard of them.
AUDIENCE: Did they
just get lucky,
or are they the best guys?
COLIN CLOUD: I
don't think there's
anything-- luck doesn't
exactly-- I mean,
these guys have
worked really hard.
They've been dedicated.
They've surrounded themselves
with the right people.
They have their own
wonderful unique skill sets.
But I think more importantly,
audiences have bought into them
as individuals.
And for me, that's
what it's really about
is people really buying
into that performer.
So regardless of
what they do, it's
them that you want
to hear more about.
And really, if we take
Dynamo, for example,
if you know who
Dynamo is, you also
know to an extent his story,
and you've bought into that.
And it's all true, but you
feel like you know him,
you have that association.
Derren had his approach.
David Blaine, when he reignited
magic on TV, certainly,
in this country, had
their own approach to it
and really found a dynamic
way of sharing magic
with audiences.
So you need to absolutely, in
my opinion, respect all of that,
because it all adds to it, and
it's all absolutely wonderful.
ROB LEWORTHY: Do you have a
collaborator you work with?
Derren works with Andy Nyman
quite a lot on his shows.
Do you work with someone?
COLIN CLOUD: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Even a
director for stage presence
and so forth.
COLIN CLOUD: For my
stage show, yeah.
The guy who's my
manager, Don, also
is like the guy who I will
speak to to everything about,
essentially.
Everything I've ever
written-- I mean, basically,
because some of the comedy
I use can be quite edgy,
I need to just run it past him
and he will rein it in or say,
"You can be a bit more
free there," and stuff.
So he's a good safety net before
I go do stuff live as well
and find the right
approach, and make sure
that it stays true
to the Sherlock stuff
that it is I love
doing on stage.
And I'm moving more into TV.
It's a case of still Don,
who I write everything with,
and branching out to
my colleague Mark who
sat over in the wings as well.
So just because
these guys have been,
certainly, Mark, involved with
TV before, and know my bringing
what I do to TV, how to
very quickly fine tune
it and make sure that--
ROB LEWORTHY: TV is a
different medium to--
COLIN CLOUD: Absolutely,
right, so it's important.
Again like Dynamo
or Darren, knowing
that you don't have
the entire skill set.
Even in the room, knowing that
we don't know how the cameras
or lights work, you
get the right people
to do those jobs to make the
complete package as good as it
can be.
ROB LEWORTHY: Final question.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys, great
performance earlier.
Magic is a performance
art where I
think you're constantly
asked to prove yourself
in every setting.
So if we have a
ballerina here, we
might not have asked her
to do a dance, for example.
I wanted to know
how that affects you
as a performer, that pressure.
COLIN CLOUD: Say the opening
again-- to prove yourself,
essentially?
In the sense of-- it's
interesting, right.
AUDIENCE: If you were
to introduce yourself
as a magician, someone would
go, "Oh, show me a trick."
COLIN CLOUD: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The good thing is
everything I do
pretty much involves the
mind, and memory, and stuff,
so I can very much
recreate what I do anywhere
with the right people
in the right mindset.
But I don't know, how
do you feel about it?
Because--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: I try to
go into these situations
by lowering their expectations,
of course, and then exceeding
them.
And you know, I do
that by dressing
like this, and your general
attitude of incompetence
and so forth.
And then hopefully, you have
something left in the bag
to wallop them with.
ROB LEWORTHY: Well we
will leave it there, and--
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Does
that answer the question?
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah, I think so.
Set expectations,
we'll take that.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: I'm not saying
when you come to our show,
lower your expectations.
I'm not saying that.
ROB LEWORTHY: It's
really very good.
DAVE WILLIAMSON:
It's me personally,
when you have lunch with me.
That's what I'm saying.
ROB LEWORTHY: Really very good.
Please join me in
a massive round
of applause for Colin and Dave.
DAVE WILLIAMSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]